this feels like a very tense moment for
Pakistan and certainly for the people of
Islamabad where we are we've been seeing
these pitch battles for the past few
hours lots of protesters throwing rocks
uh police police have in turn been
firing tear gas at them this is the
Kashmir Highway a key route into and out
of Islamabad and you can see lots of the
protesters Gathering here in the street
and about three kilometers from here
Imran Khan has been in a hearing local
report that he has been indicted on
charges of corruption accused of
illegally selling State gifts and every
now and then you get this commotion in
the crowd as people try and get their
uh
the question is whether this will be a
tipping moment a Tipping Point for
Pakistan or not is the PTI able to build
a critical mass of protesters Who come
out and most critically of course
ultimately have their voices heard when
they vote in that election that Imran
Khan wants to happen early but the
government a deeply hurt by his behavior
they're casting him is obstructionist
that he's always putting obstacles in
front of him I think the backdrop of
what we've seen occur in the past few
days
is the military establishment deciding
to say they have simply had enough and
we can soon take us just to the rights
of us here we're just going to bend down
you can see some of this coming in here
just trying to move out of the way it's
always pretty unpredictable here and I
just don't know where this goes from
here this kind of commotion is happening
every few minutes or so you can see the
prison van in the distance trying to
pick people up
and the military establishments say that
Imran Khan
has been accusing a senior military
officer of having been a bowl involved
in his assassination attempt
they feel
that he has said too much now
you can see here
just everywhere people
trying to disperse across the seats but
then they return
we'll have to wait and see what happens
in the next few hours to come